in a town noted for natural beauties one
who is and probably always will be one
of the great lovely ladies
a former Academy Award winner and a
person who had remained as she was sweet
sincere Sullivan's Donna Reed to present
the award for customers
the nominees for best achievement in
costume design of a black-and-white
picture are the arrow
Gerardi federico fellini's eight and a
half his head love with the proper
stranger
trivia a stripper
bill Thomas Toys in the Attic
eat it head wives and lovers and the
winner is euro karate
Thank You America
those nominated for best achievement in
costume design of a color picture are
Donald Brooks the Cardinal
Irene share Vittorio Nino no per se and
Rene for Cleopatra Walter Plunkett How
the West was won here autosave the
leopard
Edith Head a new kind of love
the winners are the sheriff mr. no
Baresi and Rene for Cleopatra
excepting for Aaron Sherritt and
Victoria you know Nova racing Renee
we half of miss sheriff mr. Novoa see
thank you for myself I am truly grateful